contrôle continu grand oral voilà à quoi
ressemble l'édition du bac 2021 mais il
est prévu résiste à tous ces changements
c'est l'épreuve écrite de philosophie le
monde dans son tunnel depuis 200 ans
elle ouvre le bal du bac et à la télé
c'est un reportage incontournable chaque
année ils sont nombreux et tamansourt
comme ça quel est le sujet que vous avez
pris monsieur j'ai pris le troisième
sujet parlant du sentiment de
culpabilité vis-à-vis de faux mails la
liberté comme étant quels sujets vous
choisi le travail difficile les hommes
ou aux abords mais j'ai dit que non mais
que oui avant pendant après les
témoignages de futurs bacheliers sont
recherchés pour l'édition 1960 du bac
philo léon zitrone faisaient le pied de
grue devant la maison des examens à
paris et à la sortie des candidats
toujours la même question
mademoiselle en philosophie il y avait
trois sujets trois sujets de moral quel
est celui que vous avez choisi troisième
le troisième c'est à dire quelle est à
votre avis le plus impérieux les lois
qu'elle est pile mademoiselle le respect
de la vie humaine yens et celle d'autrui
traité c'est facile
quelqu'un n'est pas d'accord derrière
moi la grotte se produire facile ou
difficile
en tout cas les preuves est souvent
redoutée et après l'examen devant la
caméra
les lycéens sont parfois partagées
exemple en 1975 à rennes c'est un marché
sa camaro je supporte salle archi moyens
français pas trop à en philo c'est pas
tellement comment ça a marché parce que
c'est parfaitement su et oui c'est toute
la difficulté de l'épreuve de philo
l'évaluation est aléatoire parfois
injuste la preuve avec l'histoire de
cette jeune fille racontait en 1994 au
jt d'antenne 2 elle n'avait obtenu que 1
sur 20 à l'épreuve de philo alors que sa
moyenne dans cette matière était de 15
toute l'année pour moi c'est de la haine
c'est truffé de points d'interrogations
point d'exclamation paraît non
d'une part on ne s'y trouve pas à la
télé le bac philo c'est aussi un bon
prétexte pour tester les personnalités
politiques et les mettre en difficulté
comme ici en 1990 oublier est la
condition la vie humaine
on aurait envie de balancer un peu
l'affirmation en disant que ce souvenir
fait partie aussi de notre condition
alors on prend dans la province comme ça
non je vais vous dire que les banalités
espérons que les 715 milles lycéens qui
passent le bac philo cette année auront
plus d'inspiration
[Musique]